we're in a space race with China NASA
administrator Bill Nelson is warning
that China might start claiming
territory on the moon you see the
actions of the Chinese government on
Earth
they go out and claim some International
islands in the South China Sea and then
they claim them as theirs so naturally I
don't want China to get to the South
Pole first with humans and then say this
is ours stay out
that's the moon's South Pole he's
talking about spacecraft have detected
large amounts of water ice in the lunar
South Pole in areas that never receive
sunlight that ice could potentially be
extracted and used for air drinking
water and Rocket Fuel NASA plans to send
a Rover called Viper in 2024 to further
explore the area Viper will drill into
the moon's surface analyzing samples to
create detailed maps of where water is
concentrated we want to make sure that
that's available to all not just the one
that's claiming it the South Pole's deep
and dark craters significantly differ
from the bright and relatively flat
surface where Neil Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin landed in 1969. they got the flag
up now and you can see the stars it's
been 50 years since the Apollo missions
we he choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard President Kennedy's challenge
set up a competition with the Soviet
Union the other great superpower at the
time
today a new competitor has emerged
China's space program is notoriously
secretive while NASA proudly streams
live video from the International Space
Station nobody knew by the spacewalks
aboard China's tiangong space station
until after they happened according to
the economist China secrecy isn't
surprising quote given the prestige at
stake Chinese officials may be inclined
to hide failures another reason is the
close ties between China's space program
and the people's Liberation Army which
demands protection of State interests
and here we go the U.S currently leads
the Space Race it spent 62 billion on
its space programs in 2022 reportedly
five times more than what China spent
the U.S has 4 500 satellites in orbit
around Earth while China has 600 but
Beijing is catching up fast it built the
Tango space station in just a year and a
half compared to the 13 years it took to
construct the ISS albeit the ISS is five
times larger the Pentagon predicts that
China will surpass the U.S and become
the dominant player in Space by 2045
China has already made remarkable
progress since sending its first
astronaut or tychonaut into space in
2003 he became the first nation to land
a spacecraft on The Far Side of the Moon
and only the second country after the
U.S to successfully operate a Rover on
Mars its next goal is to land astronauts
near the moon's South Pole by 2030. the
question is will the U.S Return To The
Moon before China gets there Artemis
plans to send a crew in late 2025 but
delays are likely NASA selected spacex's
Starship for the mission although the
fully reusable rocket hasn't yet
completed a successful orbital flight
Starship launched for the first time in
April soaring across the Texas sky
before plummeting into the Gulf of
Mexico my concern is the same because
they haven't launched NASA associate
administrator Jim free expressed his
doubts they need to launch multiple
times not just for us but for them and
then they need to launch multiple times
for us the Journey To The Moon requires
a modified Starship to launch into
Earth's orbit another Starship refuels
it before it heads on a path to the Moon
NASA's SLS will launch from Earth
carrying crew in the Orion spacecraft
which meets up with Starship in lunar
orbit astronauts will transfer from
Orion to Starship which will take them
to the moon since there's very little
atmosphere on the moon Starship is
modified to do without fins for landing
for the trip home Starship meets up with
Orion left in lunar orbit the crew
transfers over to Orion for the return
to Earth
but imagine a scenario where the SLS and
Orion aren't needed Starship could
launch with the crew aboard Rendezvous
for refueling with another Starship and
then head to the moon this version of
Starship retains its heat shield and
flaps ensuring a safe and controlled
descent for landing back on Earth
China is planning its own version of
Starship the Long March 9 but it's
believed to be a decade away
Starship may be NASA's pivotal asset in
outpacing China in space NASA's
relationship with SpaceX is one of its
169 International Partnerships a network
far more extensive than China's
alliances with Russia Iran Pakistan
Thailand and turkey the possibility of
the U.S and China working together is
off the table Congress passed the wolf
amendment in 2011 which prohibits NASA
from working with Chinese
government-owned entities due to fears
of technological theft risks to National
Security and worries about human rights
abuses
so the U.S and China are on separate
paths to the Moon whoever wins the race
could gain a considerable Advantage as
the Moon is considered to be the
critical stepping stone to Mars the race
is on and the stakes are high
a family-run Aerospace machine shop in
Canada that built parts for the Mars
rover and the ISS pivoted during the
pandemic to create something unique
The Henson al-13 is engineered to hold
the blade at a perfect 30 degree angle
to give you a smoother closer shave most
razors don't support the blades enough
which allows the blade to flex or
vibrate more along your skin causing
irritation in razor burn Henson razors
are also a good investment the blades
cost 10 cents so it'll cost just three
to five dollars a year to shave that's
less than cartridges or electric razors
in the long run Henson ships globally
I've already gifted a few of these to my
friends who are impressed with the
quality and the craftsmanship and by
using my code Muse think you'll get 100
blades for free be sure to add them to
your cart first click the custom link in
my description and try a Henson today